si tu essayé mais seul il me sourit puis
dans les avenues
[Musique]
qui tu es bon tu parais
les rires ont mis du temps avant de
revenir dans cette maison de manouane
certains gestes coiffer les cheveux de
jessica ou faire le biberon de carole
juniors sont même devenus le nouveau
quotidien pour ce père de sept enfants
est aussi grand père
complètement perturbé même les enfants
je me suis découvert qu'ils avaient de
petites aval comme des tâches ménagères
le coiffeur et vinifie
de la cuisine que j'apprends encore à l'
approche de noël le sapin est prêt il
porte la couleur mauve celle qui
symbolise la femme dont carole dubé est
tombé amoureux au premier regard une
femme présente à travers des souvenirs
partout dans la maison mais si absente
l'année 2020 avait pourtant bien
commencé pour ce couple à la vie simple
ensemble pendant 23 ans on n'était pas
les coupes parfaites
des mauvaises années
on a fini sur une très belle année la
régulière cet événement
en échange elle avait fait main demain
cette bague de mariage avec laquelle
carole dubé joue sans arrêt dès que
l'émotion le submerge joyce ne lui aura
jamais passé au doigt mais le fait que
le 28 septembre 2020 il est dans sa
cuisine en train de faire le ménage
thomas 17 ans surgit complètement
bouleversé
[Musique]
ce que lui montre thomas c'est cette
vidéo est une autre prise par la fille
aînée en train de prier à voix basse
près de joyce et chaque one inerte au 6
de lanaudière une vidéo frappé par un
interdit de publication
[Musique]
depuis plus d'un an la vie de karol dubé
ce sont les montagnes russes d'émotions
poliment il répond toujours en premier
qu'il va bien et pourtant les verts
première
je suis très très fatigué
nasa comme un petit goût de total des
ailes et c'est unique à doute que je
reçois
des artères
seul mais aussi de son propre aveu bien
entouré carole dubé a reçu tellement de
messages de soutien des cadeaux aussi
dont ses portraits car malgré lui carl
dubé est devenu le porte parole d'une
cause la voulait dénoncer
qu'est ce que
c'est
qu'est ce qu'il niera 6 y vivent
donc trop silencieux de la systémique
arabe
près du cimetière où reposent déjà vexé
chaque one le site de ressourcement en
mijery mowin dans le chapitre one où la
chaleur du feu et l'odeur du sapinage
offre un certain réconfort carole
entouré de deux proches prend une pause
dans ce tourbillon médiatique politique
de vie il semble parfois à bout de
souffle mais il se relève avec en tête
une mission à accomplir
je dois continuer à porter
qui tombent dans l'oubli ça mange
pas ça il faut que son sacrifice c'est
là quelque chose parce qu ils lapident
des habiletés
c'est quelque chose qui rappela alors
quand l'émotion le submerge il a des
verts sans mots dans un carnet intime
parfois aussi sur facebook paris lé ton
ferme il les yeux
tu nous as auvergne mienne
on a tous pris du
avec toute la nation humain
en simple on a marché
insidieuse de ton action